there are of course the examples that
you open up and see in the newspaper
everyday like british petroleum and
goldman sachs and toyota those companies
are a warning flag to every other
business that's not doing the right
thing you know those businesses happen
to have gotten caught in the mess that
they've created they are not alone in
doing some terrible things but they're
unique in that they have gotten caught
if you go back in time and you think
about a company like Toyota several
years ago while they were running all of
these ads about the Prius and how
sustainable the prius is and how much
they cared about the planet and the
environment at the same time secretly
they were lobbying in California against
increased gas mileage standards so you
know on the one hand they wanted to
appear as this sustainable company wow
you know with the other hand that
they're actually fighting the changes
that are required to make the world more
sustainable for everyone else that is
the kind of duality that I see at too
many companies too many companies who
want to talk about I mean I remember I
remember for years ago General Motors
put up billboards all around New York
and the the country advertising the
vault car now the vole car was not being
made they had no idea if it was going to
be made they had no idea when it was
going to be made but that didn't stop
them from advertising a car that didn't
exist as a way to bolster their image as
a responsible business you know things
like that are destructive to your
reputation and many companies don't
understand that this new world that we
live in the the transparency that is
created by the internet raises the state
for companies getting away with stuff
that they used to be able to get away
with transparency will be forced upon
you if you choose not to be transparent
yourself and you will get caught doing
the wrong thing whether you get caught
by your own employees whether you get
caught by a blogger whether you get
caught by a NGO or the government you'll
get caught and businesses need to be
proactive in a disclosing the problems
that they have which they're scared to
do and committing to the path that
they're going to take two to make change